[Musique]
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui dans science clic le
rayonnement de hawking notre univers est
décrit par deux théories la relativité
générale qui décrit la trame de
l'univers comme une surface lisse qui
peut se courber l'espace temps et la
théorie quantique des champs qui décrit
les particules comme des petits paquets
d'énergie à l'intérieur de chant
quantique
ces deux théories fonctionne extrêmement
bien et modélisent dans leurs domaines
respectifs presque tout ce que l'on
connaît mais malheureusement elles sont
actuellement inconciliables les calculs
ne parviennent pas à décrire l'origine
microscopique de la gravité la façon
dont les particules des paquets
discontinue d'énergie peuvent courbet
une surface continue comme l'espace
temps cela dit il reste possible
d'étudier le comportement de particules
quantiques à l'intérieur d'un espace
temps courbes mais que l'on imagine figé
en négligeant le fait que les particules
devraient influencer sa courbure
c'est par un calcul astucieux de ce type
qu'en 1974
stephen hawking découvre un phénomène
étonnant hawking découvre que les trous
noirs produisent un rayonnement très
léger qui à terme les fait s'évaporer
un phénomène qui mélange gravité et
physique quantique le rayonnement de
hawking
[Musique]
un trou noir est une région sphérique
une bulle d'espace-temps délimité par un
horizon à l'intérieur duquel la gravité
est si intense que rien ne peut
s'échapper quand ils sont entourés de
matières les trous noirs rayonne et on
peut le détecter depuis la terre
toutefois ce rayonnement n'est qu'un
direct il provient de la matière à
l'extérieur du trou noir
le trou noir en lui même n'est pas
vraiment un objet mais plutôt une région
et donc a priori il ne rayonne pas au
niveau de l'horizon l'espace est vide
mais ce serait oublier la physique
quantique
d'après la théorie quantique notre
univers contient des champs qui
remplissent tout l'espace sont présents
partout même dans ce qu'on appelle le
vide les champs quantiques sont agités
de fluctuation ils contiennent des ondes
qu'on appelle des particules virtuelles
certaines d'énergies positives et
d'autres d'énergie négative le vide en
théorie quantique et simplement l'état
dans lequel les ondes positives et
négatives se compense parfaitement les
fluctuations du chant quantiques sont
toujours présentes mais rien ne s'y
propage
une particule réel est une onde qui
n'est pas compensée et donc se propage
revenons à la relativité le mouvement
naturel des corps dans l'espace temps et
la chute libre le tissu de l'univers est
courbé et les objets ont tendance à
avancer tout droit dans l'espace temps
ce qui les entraînent dans leur chute
on peut représenter la courbure autour
d'un trou noir par une grille qui se
contracte en accélérant au cours du
temps un objet au repos reste immobile
ou en mouvement à vitesse constante par
rapport à cette grille al'inverse un
objet qui voudraient s'opposer à ce
mouvement naturel de la grille est forcé
d'exercer une accélération pour
s'empêcher de tomber localement l'espace
temps semble plat la courbure n'est
visible qu à grande échelle comme sur
terre ainsi un observateur en chute
libre n'observe rien de spécial et en
particulier il n'observe rien de spécial
au moment de franchir l'horizon du trou
noir
on a vu que l'espace autour du trou noir
est vide et c'est le cas en particulier
au niveau de l'horizon la théorie
quantique des champs décrit le vide par
un équilibre d'onde positives et
négatives
ces ondes sont définis par rapport à la
grille de l'espace temps elles sont dans
un état naturel au repos et un
observateur en chute libre
deux mesures donc aucune particule il
mesure bien le vide mais maintenant
imaginons un observateur qui lui restent
stationnées juste au dessus de l'horizon
pour éviter de tomber cet observateur
efforcé d'accélérer constamment mais
parce qu'ils accélèrent par rapport à la
grille il perçoit les ondes positives et
négatives de façon différente en
accélérant par rapport à ces ondes il
les reçoit avec des fréquences des
formes et en particulier les ondes qui
se trouve sous l'horizon ne seront
jamais reçu par l'observateur qui
accélère vers l'extérieur
la personne en chute libre ne détecte
pas l'horizon du trou noir pour l
localement l'horizon est un endroit
comme les autres et les ondes positives
et négatives si compense l'espace
évident mais la personne qui s'empêchent
de tomber elle détecte l'horizon car
elle accélère si bien qu'elles empêchent
certaines ondes de l'atteindre
pour elle les ondes positives et
négatives ne se compensent pas de son
point de vue l'espace n'est pas vide
il est rempli de particules
[Musique]
il est crucial de comprendre que les
notions de vide et de particules sont
relatives parce qu'ils se déplacent
différemment dans l'espace temps les
deux observateurs détecte les
fluctuations des champs quantique de
façon différente
tandis que l'un voix du vide l'autre
voix des particules au niveau de
l'horizon du trou noir
on ne peut pas dire de façon absolue
qu'il existe ou non des particules
la notion est relative l'existence de
ces particules dépens de l'observateur
[Musique]
jusqu'ici le raisonnement était purement
locale la notion de particules est
relative
dès lors qu'on a un observateur qui
accélère que l'on soit à côté d'un trou
noir ou dans un espace-temps plat mais
dans notre cas
l'espace ton est courbé à grande échelle
et alors que la notion de particules est
purement relatives au niveau de
l'horizon plus on s'éloigne du trou noir
plus l'immobilité qui constituait un
mouvement accéléré au niveau de l'
horizon devient le mouvement naturel
ces particules qui existe de façon
relative au niveau de l' horizon
deviennent peu à peu des particules réel
en s'éloignant du trou noir
ainsi les trous noirs rayonne
c'est le rayonnement de hawking les
particules virtuelles près de l'horizon
deviennent des particules réel à grande
distance
la courbure de l'espace-temps fait la
transition entre une zone où il faut
accélérer pour rester immobile et une
zone où l'immobilité est naturelle on
comprend bien que ce rayonnement ne
provient pas de l'intérieur du trou noir
rien ne sort du trou noir les particules
que l'on détecte à grande distance
prennent leur origine dans les
fluctuations du vide à l'extérieur de
l'horizon une façon intuitive
d'interpréter le phénomène est
d'imaginer le vide comme une soupe de
particules virtuelles qui apparaissent
par paire une d'énergie positive l'autre
d'énergie négative et kiss and il
aussitôt
[Musique]
d'ordinaire ces particules virtuelles ne
peuvent pas devenir de vrais particules
elle reste indétectable notamment parce
qu'une vraie particules doit forcément
avoir une énergie positive ses pairs de
particules virtuelles dont l'une est
d'énergie négative doivent donc
disparaître aussitôt mais à l'intérieur
d'un trou noir
la courbure est si intense que les
notions de temps et d'espacé s'inverse
d'un point de vue externe
ceci autorise les particules qui sont à
l'intérieur du trou noir avoir une
énergie négative
lorsqu'une père virtuel apparaît à
l'horizon du trou noir
la particule négative a donc une chance
d'exister si elle est capturée par le
trou noir
elle est désormais autorisé à devenir
une particule réel tandis que la
particule positive de s'échapper du trou
noir
en absorbant ces particules négatives
le trou noir perd peu à peu de l'énergie
samas diminue et petit à petit le
rayonnement de hawking fait s'évaporer
les trous noirs
le rayonnement de hawking est ce qu'on
appelle un rayonnement thermique le
spectre de ce rayonnement correspond
parfaitement aux spectres émis par un
objet du fait de sa température
on peut ainsi attribuer une température
au trou noir correspondant à l'énergie
de leur rayonnement
les gros trous noirs sont très froids
car au niveau de l'horizon la courbure
se fait très peu ressentir il s'évapore
donc très lentement et plus un trou noir
est petit plus son rayonnement et
énergétiques correspondant à une
température élevée
[Musique]
il s'agit là d'une propriété
intéressante des trous noirs
d'ordinaire lorsqu'un corps perd de
l'énergie en rayonnant sa température
diminue mais un trou noir qui perd de
l'énergie en rayonnant rétrécit et sa
température augmente en perdant de
l'énergie
les trous noirs se réchauffe et
l'évaporation s'accélère de plus en plus
cela dit tous les trous noirs que l'on
connaît pèse plusieurs milliards de
milliards de milliards de tonnes car il
se forme à partir de l'effondrement des
toiles massive leur rayonnement est
extrêmement faible
sa température ne dépasse pas quelques
milliardièmes de degré au dessus du zéro
absolu
et il n'est composé que de particules
sans masse comme les photons le
processus d'évaporation et donc
complètement négligeable
il faudrait plusieurs milliers de
milliards de milliards de milliards de
fois l'âge de l'univers pour les voir
s'évaporer
qui plus est l'univers est rempli d'un
rayonnement issus du big bang le fond
diffus cosmologique et en absorbant ce
rayonnement
en réalité les trous noirs grossistes si
l'énergie du fond diffus cosmologique
diminue à mesure que l'univers s'expose
l'évaporation pourrait un jour prendre
le dessus mais il faudrait pour cela
attendre plusieurs centaines de
milliards d'années
toutefois il pourrait potentiellement
existait deux petits trous noirs
primordiaux formé juste après le big
bang dont l' évaporation pourrait être
en cours
s'il existe on espère que leur
rayonnement sera détectable un jour pour
le moment
le rayonnement de hawking reste un
résultat théorique impossible à détecter
à l'heure actuelle et qui se base sur
une approximation négliger l'effet des
particules sur la géométrie de l'espace
temps il nous faudra très certainement
attendre de disposer d'une véritable
théorie de la gravitation quantique pour
comprendre ce phénomène avec exactitude
en particulier les derniers instants de
l'évaporation
quand le rayonnement devient très
intense mais il s'agit tout de même
d'une prédiction très solide
beaucoup de calcul différent aboutissent
à ces mêmes conclusions
en 1974 ou king calculé l'effondrement
gravitationnel d'une étoile et la façon
dont le trou noir en formation affecte
les champs quantique une méthode plus
abstraite consiste à étudier le temps
non plus comme un nombre réel mais comme
un nombre imaginaire il s'agit là d'une
technique de physique statistique le
temps imaginaire re boucle sur lui même
et on retrouve la température du trou
noir avec la longueur de ses boucles
[Musique]
expérimentalement
on étudie déjà le phénomène en utilisant
des analogies en particulier on peut
créer en laboratoire un écoulement de
fluides qui reproduit les conditions
d'un trou noir avec une sorte d'
horizons qui sépare un écoulement
supersonique d'un écoulement plus lent
d'un côté les ondes sonores peuvent
s'échapper
de l'autre le fluide et en plus rapide
elles sont capturés ces analogies ne
sont pas parfaites mais les équations
qui les décrivent sont proches de celles
du vrai phénomène et plusieurs
expériences aboutissent à des résultats
prometteurs les calculs de hawking et
les recherches qui ont suivi ont
contribué à découvrir des passerelles
entre gravitation et physique quantique
ouvrant les premières pistes vers une
unification des deux théories pour la
première fois une formule celle qui
donne la température d'un trou noir fait
intervenir toutes les constantes de la
physique moderne un phénomène réunissant
relativité gravitation physique
quantique et thermodynamique le
phénomène d'évaporation des trous noirs
soulève des questions et engendre des
paradoxes sur notre compréhension de la
physique moderne
d'ordinaire en physique à partir d'un
état final il est possible en théorie de
remonter à l'état initial d'un système
mais deux trous noirs parfaitement
identiques peuvent se former à partir de
deux étoiles différentes
et une fois ces trous noirs évaporé il
ne resterait plus aucune trace du
scénario qui s'est produit c'est le
paradoxe de l'information l'information
de ce qui a été capturé par un trou noir
semble se perdre à tout jamais une fois
évaporée peut-être que cette information
reste figé à l'horizon et est capturé et
puis emporté par le rayonnement de
hawking ou peut-être que le trou noir ne
disparaît pas totalement et laisse un
minuscule résidus derrière lui qui
contiendrait toutes ces informations
pour le moment nous ne savons pas encore
enfin depuis quelques années le
rayonnement de hawking a permis de
mettre en lumière un paradoxe encore
plus fort lié au fait que les particules
virtuelles qui se séparent à l'horizon
devrait rester intriqués entre elles
ce paradoxe fait ressortir les limites
de nos modèles actuels dont certains
fondements devront être abandonnés dans
l'espoir de découvrir un jour une
théorie du tout l'une des approches pour
résoudre ce problème et d'abandonner le
principe d'équivalence selon lequel rien
de spécial ne se produit au niveau de
l'horizon d'un trou noir
certains pensent qu'il existerait un
mécanisme qui brisent violemment
l'intrication entre la particule qui
s'échappe et celle qui tombe dans le
trou noir
une sorte de mur de feu
[Musique]